big Lynch good to talk to you this
morning can I ask you what you thought
of the budget first of all was there
anything in there for you
no there's no uh move from the
government to solve these public sector
pay disputes there's certainly nothing
that we can recognize for the railway
and it seems to be a budget for the rich
and there'll be a continuous transfer of
wealth from working people because the
tax thresholds for ordinary workers have
not gone up but for the wealthy they can
put up to sixty thousand pounds a year
into their pension scheme and they will
have unlimited tax break
on their lifetimes earnings so it seems
A peculiar pension A peculiar step to
take where you're giving more money to
the wealthy and taking money off the
poor and that's a transfer of wealth in
our society which we saw under list
trust and quasi-quarting and Jeremy
Hunt's going the same way it seems
let's move on to what's actually
happening today with you and the ongoing
strikes that the rail delivery group
says that the rmt has been offered nine
percent over two years and 13
specifically to the lowest paid workers
is that true and if so why haven't you
accepted it
well we haven't accepted it because it's
a really poor offer it's rubbish really
it's way below the rate of inflation yes
members haven't uh well I'll tell you
what if you let me answer we've had a I
haven't had a pay increase for three
years our members during that period
have been subject to an inflation rate
on the retail price index of over 22 and
they've been offered nine percent over
two years but they have to fund that
themselves
through cuts to their their terms and
conditions changes to their working
practices reductions in pay rates uh
across the industry and of course the
closure of every book in office in the
country and that's unacceptable to us we
should get new money on the table we
shouldn't have to accept all these
changes to our conditions in an industry
that is 24 7. we need proper agreed
rules on rostering and Staffing and
accessibility for people who want to use
our Railway and all these companies are
interested in is maximizing their
profits and what we need to understand
is that since the pandemic they have
made over 420 million pounds in profit
these train operating companies they're
currently running profits at over 118
million pound a year they're paying
their Chief Executives the first group
chief executive had an increase last
year of
it is remuneration his finance officer
had over 150 percent uh increase
remuneration so they are literally fat
cats getting rich on the back of our
members work and the extortion of fares
that the public have to pay while
they're telling us we can't have a pay
rise that's unacceptable
you say it's a rubbish offer 99 over two
years 13 of the lowest paid but uh
according to the Guardian newspaper a
similar officer has been given to
network rail at staff there and that's
been put to referendum which we're
expecting to get a result on next Monday
I mean they clearly don't think it's
it's that rubbish an offer if they're
willing to put it to their workers
shouldn't you put it to your workers
anyway and see what your workers think
of it whether or not they think it's a
rubbish offer
well it's an increased offer it's a
better offer than the train operating
companies have made so and the details
are in that offer there's an extra
amount of money and there's back dating
that's in that offer and that's why it's
been put to a referendum those
negotiations have concluded at the
moment we went to our members thousands
of them and did a mass consultation on
the details of this offer and the money
issue wasn't the main priority it's the
conditions and The Ripping up of our
contracts of employment and the dilution
of our terms and conditions that has
caused this offer to be stuck so they
need to improve what they want to pay
our members and they can afford that
because of the extortion of profits
they're making from the fair payer and
the taxpayer and they could maintain our
conditions through agreement in
negotiations they're unwilling to do
that because they want to make those
profits even bigger and if you take all
these companies a bellio go ahead and
first group and so on they're nearly all
subject to takeover bids from private
Equity companies because they see that
if they drive down to conditions in this
industry they can maximize profit so
there are overseas Equity companies that
want to take these companies over and
and drive up the corporate return for
their dividend holders and shareholders
we don't find that acceptable we want a
balanced deal for our people that
retains their conditions of employment
and gets them a decent pay increase and
that's not on the table at the moment
do you think passengers care about that
do you not think passengers just want to
be able to get to work do you think do
you think they mind what the motivation
is you're saying that the motivation for
for what the companies are doing is all
money the companies will say that their
motivation is is to make the businesses
run better but as far as passengers are
concerned they don't care what the
motivation is they just want the trains
to be running and there are there are
people who can't get to work today get
their kids to school today because once
again you're on strike
I'm here at Houston Station and we've
had the most appalling train service
that any Railway company has provided in
history and if you take if you take a
northern Rail and Transplant iron
Express what these companies specialize
in is failure they've proven time and
again that they are incapable of running
the railway so what the passengers want
I believe is a is a decent competent
management system where they can expect
a reliable and safe Railway at a
reasonable price these train operating
companies have succeeded in extracting
profit billions of pounds of profits
into privatization and have totally
degraded our Railway system they haven't
invested a penny all of the investment
in the railway comes from the taxpayer
it goes straight into the hands of
Rolling Stock leasing companies and the
people that lose out are the staff and
the passengers so what we need to do is
get rid of these these middlemen who all
they specialize in collecting dividends
and fares off the off the taxpayer and
get a decent system of Railway operation
which is a square deal for the
passengers the staff and the taxpayer as
well and what we need to do is change
the system because they're all they're
interested in is farming revenue and
paying it out in dividends for their
people and that's what the passengers
should get as a contract from this
government rather than the exploitation
they're currently getting the
preparation
passengers want to understand
if you speak to everybody
if you speak to everybody in the north
of England at the minute and anyone who
wants to use West Coast Railways they
can't rely on getting to work even when
we're not on strike there's more
disruption women not on strike than when
we are in some cases it's an appalling
system and the people that are running
our Railway at the moment have proven
themselves completely incompetent so
what we need to do is get a settle into
this dispute and then get on with
reforming and restructuring our Railway
in the interest of the public in the
interest of the passenger in the
interest of our economy and our
environment that's what we need to do
that's the task in front of us and that
would start with resolving this dispute
with a decent offer to our members that
we could put to a referendum
you see there are others who say that
actually because of the number of strike
days they are now considering different
ways of working and ways that have
worked around since covered people are
much happier now working from home
absolutely you know for a lot of the
time and some would argue that you're
actually striking your your own way out
of a job because you're going to
contribute to the railways becoming less
popular less reliable people are going
to stop relying on the railways
well I don't think that's true that's a
government line that you're punting out
on their behalf they come out you don't
know I always excuse me I'm talking to
you about conversations I've had please
I'm not going to have you stand there
and accuse me of being a government
mouthpiece I'm a human being I'm a
middle-aged woman and I'm a journalist
and I'm talking to you about
conversations I've had with people I
know this has got nothing to do with the
government it's exactly the phraseology
that I hear across the table from
government ministers almost verbatim so
there you go maybe you're just very in
tune with what they say so I turn to the
railway we've got okay well I thought
maybe they're in tune with the
government as well so we've got to
return to Railways we've got a return to
profit making by these companies and
we've got to return to Fair hikes so
what we need to do is change the system
we need to get a railway that's reliable
so that people can use it so they can
get back into our towns and cities
revive the economy for the hospitality
industry and all the other people that
rely on the railways and public
transport but what we're seeing now is a
government that's determined to drive
down public transport usage whether
that's on the buses or the railway fares
are being hiked services are becoming
more and more unreliable and the problem
is that there is not a coherent Railway
system in our country it is completely
fractured and broken and we need to
revise that and get a decent system
that's in all our interests